on the next all you Rick and Morty
that's the end of the morning it's a
dragon episode are you going to say it
first off I always slay it queen
secondly yes prepared better for this
terrifying battle by remembering the
only thing dragons are known for
the episode starts when Rick and Morty
are on an adventure and they find that
something that they've been looking for
has been stolen by a heist expert named
Miles Knightley's a hack piece of
I'm going to get him Kubrick has a serious
not just grudge against Pete just thinks
everything he does is active mainly
because like if you just want the thing
you should steal the thing why do you
have to make a big elaborate deal out of
it
what's the job that was it fine yes
Rick's disdain for the Heinz honor is
absolutely based on mine yeah I think I
think Justin watched some heist movies
that might be hest thoroughly enjoyed
them in the same way I enjoyed the room
or troll - he like would text me it's
like holy dude will you get to the
end you're like what the are you
talking what's gonna Mike I know I know
ridiculous to believe that I programmed
you to believe that I actually really
liked heist movies and loved when you
find out that it really was Brad Pitt
that um is in the SWAT team uniform and
you know that's like the kind of stuff
that I like the police were us in police
outfits
I mean look I'll be the first to say
like I don't think you should make
episodes based on your hatred of
something whatever man
like I'm I just think it's ironic that
the heist genre steals so much money
from culture
catch an all-new episode in two weeks
only on Adult Swim welcome back everyone
it's Charlie this is going to be my Rick
and Morty season 4 episode 4 trailer
video the title is claw and horror
special ricktum morty obviously a
reference to Law & Order Special Victims
Unit so we'll break all the Easter eggs
down there's also going to be a two-week
break before episode 4 so I'll remind
everybody about that at the end of the
video if you're new to the channel I'm
doing Easter egg videos for every
episode be sure to subscribe to get
everything we're doing a weekly Rick and
Morty merch giveaway - Rick breaks the
fourth wall again at the beginning of
the clip when he says and that's the end
of the Morty gets a dragon episode
he's known he's been in a fictional TV
show since early in season one when he
started looking at the camera at the end
of episodes I put all the fourth wall
breaks from the first three seasons and
one of my trailer videos a while ago so
I'll put a link for that down in the
video description here because he breaks
the fourth wall and pretty much every
single episode and sometimes it'll
happen multiple times per episode
fun fact easter egg because of the
law-and-order title lawn Order SVU is
also the show that iced tea has been on
for a billion years but when they did
the water tea character during get
schwifty it was actually Dan Harmon
doing an iced tea impression a couple
years ago when that episode first aired
iced tea was totally not a fan of it I
think Dan Harmon says something about
iced tea thinking that he and Justin
were on drugs when they came up with a
concept for the water tea character but
then a couple years after that when
season 3 aired ice tea had completely
180 down the series and started praising
the show openly on his Twitter account
he even posted this tweet here so maybe
if their schedules work out there's a
chance they could have him back on to
cameo as another character if they
didn't want to straight up go back to
the numeric cons water tea space battle
that they ended on in that post-credit
scene there's a lot of big celebrities
that love Rick and Morty and openly will
tweet back and forth with Dan Justin and
the official Rick and Morty Twitter
account but that doesn't automatically
mean that they're going to cameo on the
show like Chris Evans Captain America
himself is a huge Rick and Morty fan he
was tweeting about it before season 4
started so don't be surprised if in a
future season at some point you hear
Chris Evans pop up as a character
episode but in the scene from Episode
four summer and Rick are just sitting in
the living room casually when it seems
like Morty's dragon is living under the
house in a cave that they make for it
starts breathing fire through the
floorboards Rick starts making fun of
science fiction and fantasy tropes again
like he does in every single episode
when summer asks him if he's going to
slay the dragon yes and I always slay
Queen a lot of people are assuming that
that's more of a pop culture RuPaul drag
race reference when he says I always
slay Queen but even though Rick and
Morty is mostly a science fiction show
it seems like this episode in particular
is them skewering fantasy tropes using
science fiction to explain how morty
gets a dragon in the first place
rick and morty hasn't done a ton of
fantasy based episodes but just like
star wars is a blend of genres we call
it science fantasy Rick and Morty is
also the kind of show that can do that
really easily and if you're not a big
Dan Harmon fan or you haven't been
following his stuff for a couple years
most people know him from community or
from Harmon town but he's also had a
long-running
Dungeons & Dragons role-playing game
series within his harmontown show called
Harmon quest it's kind of like his
version of critical role they do this
live-action role-playing game with
Dungeons and Dragons episode 2 episode they even turned the Harmon quest
Dungeons & Dragons game that they play
week to week into an animated series but
I don't think that they're producing
episodes for that anymore
so Dan Harmon himself is a big fan of
the fantasy genre and Dungeons & Dragons
and even back during season 3 when it
was airing at the same time as Game of
Thrones Season 7 during the summer of
2017 he spent every week posting
pictures of himself watching Game of
Thrones episodes in his bedroom so you
remember the whole debacle where Adult
Swim was taking shots at Game of Thrones
season 7 with that infamous title card
that ran during a Rick and Morty episode
or IP Game of Thrones writing 2011 to
2016 Dan Harmon got super pissed after
that because people thought that he was
responsible for the joke because the
joke happened during a Rick and Morty
episode he even had to make a statement
about it on his Instagram account I
won't read the whole thing here but it's
basically him calling out Adult Swim for
putting that on his episode without his
approval based on his explanation it was
just some random Adult Swim intern
making those interstitials but even
though the final seasons of Game of
Thrones were really divisive he did
saying his post the Game of Thrones was
still his favorite TV show
so given his longtime love of the
fantasy genre and Dungeons & Dragons
he even did Dungeons & Dragons episodes
of community don't be surprised if Rick
and Morty starts doing a lot more
fantasy based or science fantasy based
episodes and if you're a big fan of
playing Dungeons & Dragons in real life
they actually did a Rick and Morty
Dungeons & Dragons starter kit that you
can buy right now but then Rick goes
down into the cave beneath the house to
slay the dragon and then they turn it
into more of a Lord of the Rings Hobbit
parody because this dragon seems more
like a version of Smaug with his giant
pile of gold that he's sleeping on in
the Smaug parody also syncs with the
title of the episode because claw and
hoarder dragon's hoard gold particularly
Smaug look at some of the other treasure
items that he's got stashed here too on
top of this pile of gold this statue in
the back is the venus de milo probably
one of the most famous ancient greek
statues he's also got a purple sports
car that kind of looks like a tesla
which makes sense because Dan and Justin
are friends with Elon Musk in real life
and they just had him on for big guest
role during episode 3 as Ilan tusks Dan
also bought himself a Tesla Model S a
little while ago so I wouldn't be
surprised that this is the animators
just working those little funny Elon
Musk Easter eggs into the background of
episodes when the dragon roars and
Brie's flame on Rick it kind of sounds
like Keith David is doing the voice but
I can't tell for sure without actually
hearing the dragon speak words Keith
David has done so many different Rick
and Morty characters I wouldn't be
surprised if this was just the next one
then his Rick does and every single
episode starts to make fun of the tropes
of the genre this case being more
fantasy based oh no it burns if only I'd
prepared for the only thing dragons are
known for breathing fire revealing that
he's actually a hologram projection I
did a rundown of some of Rick's many
personal defense weapons he has built
into his clothes or himself in one of my
previous trailer videos because he also
hides a lot of weapons inside his body
like the fake mechanical arm that he
showed off during episode 3 in surprise
the real Rick has gone full ninja in a
stealth suit trying to slay the dragon
to a traditional way by jumping onto its
back behind the head we don't know much
else about the episode so it's kind of
hard to tell what the B story is going
to be or where Morty is and all this or
what's going on with Beth and Jerry but
they usually post the opening scene the
weekend before the episode airs so
they do that I'll make a new easter egg
video but big heads up if you didn't
catch it during the trailer they're
skipping this week in episode 4 won't
drop for two more weeks they're skipping
because the Thanksgiving holidays so
I'll remind everyone when I do my next
Rick and Morty video the second clip is
funny for a whole bunch of different
reasons because you have Dan Harmon who
sounds like he's trying to talk himself
out of making episode 3 about all the
heist movie tropes but they've already
made the episode when he's talking about
this then on the other side you have the
writer of the episode in some of the
other people talking about why they like
the things that they did during the
episode I like heist movies thoroughly
enjoyed them in the same way I enjoyed
the room or troll too he would text me
it's like holy dude will you get to
the end you're like what the are
you talking what I'm like I know I know
even if you didn't like this week's
episode I still think that an episode of
Rick and Maury that's just okay is still
better than most other TV shows so even
if it's not the best episode ever is
still pretty solid I think that after
season 3 what happened though is that
because the super long break fans just
had crazy high expectations for what
season 4 would be so if you spotted any
other Easter eggs in the trailer that I
didn't mention in the video write them
below in the comments I'm working on a
new Mandalorian video new DC and Marvel
all that stuff we'll post in the next
couple of days everyone click here for
my Rick and Morty season 4 episode 3
video and click here for my new
Mandalorian baby yoda video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight